Hier soir, j'ai pensé que j'allais juste
déterrer ces choses et j'ai demandé votre
autographe oh mon dieu qu'est-ce que j'ai écrit beaucoup,
lisez-le c'est tellement agréable de vous voir
qu'est-ce qu'il a dit euh cher hbc ouais c'était
un plaisir d'être votre  co-star et
coaster
wow
quel jeu de mots intelligent j'ai fait quand
j'étais jeune je veux dire honnêtement je suis toujours assez
content de ça ouais
dans le sens où j'ai toujours fini par
tenir ton café je t'aime alors
qu'est-ce que ça fait  ça dit que
je peux nous pouvons partager ça maintenant j'ai dit que
je t'aime et j'aurais juste aimé être né
10 ans plus tôt j'aurais peut-être été
avec une chance
beaucoup d'amour et merci d'être cool
n'est-ce pas agréable
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous